i
bienvenidos a este programa de fin de
año sobre perú han transcurrido más de
cuatro meses desde que el presidente
pedro casi asumió el poder la
inestabilidad política ha sido una
constante durante este corto periodo de
su mandato el gobernante ha obligado a
algunos ministros a dimitir ante
diversos cuestionamientos y estas
decisiones han orientado a los
inversionistas en los económicos en la
era casi a la nación andina viene una
inflación más alta de los últimos 12
años reduciendo cada día el poder
adquisitivo de la población entretanto
la oposición sigue un constante ataque
con el bloqueo en el parlamento a
iniciativas del gobierno sesiones de
interpelación a ministros y la constante
amenaza de destitución a castillo
mediante el proceso de vacancia
presidencial por otra parte el escándalo
del ex secretario de la presidencia a
bruno pacheco a quien la fiscalía le
requisó 20 mil dólares escondidos en un
baño de palacio de gobierno mientras era
investigado por supuestamente manipular
los ascensos de algunos militares ha
desplomado a la aceptación del
mandatario peruano un 59 por ciento de
los ciudadanos lo desaprueba según un
sondeo de opinión de la encuestadora
datum caminando por este país no es
difícil encontrar a ciudadanos que dicen
sentirse desilusionados de su presidente
en la siguiente historia conoceremos su
apatía con el gobierno que no ha traído
el cambio que esperaban
ulises rodríguez y sus amigos viajaron
casi 600 km para protestar en las calles
de lima
al igual que muchos peruanos que votaron
por pedro castillo está enojado porque
el gobernante no ha cumplido sus
promesas electorales de mejorar la vida
de la población maya cienciano toda la
oportunidad ya no se justifica su
existencia de permanencia del gobierno
no ni un día más tengamos que acudir al
congreso el ha debido salir por su
propio medio su propia intención sí que
la tiene lamentablemente no la tiene el
presidente pedro casi o no satisface a
sus electores ni a sus socios políticos
carece de una sólida bancada que lo
respalde en el congreso sin embargo tras
negociar con algunos partidos lo que un
proceso de destitución que impulsó la
derecha que controla el parlamento a la
que acusa de boicotear su gestión nunca
aceptaron que un campesino un rondero un
maestro dirija la nación y que promueva
cambios estructurales en el país
el objetivo de estos grupos es bajar al
presidente sin ningún sustento vencer a
sus rivales en poder a pedro casi y
diversos analistas sostienen que si el
parlamento insiste en otro proceso de
impeachment el mandatario podría
ejecutar medidas radicales y también eso
hace que la situación sea más riesgosa
porque de pronto puede caer en manos de
un sector extremista que lo secuestre y
lo haga dependiente de él y lleve al
país a una ruptura del estado de derecho
la situación es crítica por esa
debilidad del gobernante aunque han
transcurrido más de 100 días de gobierno
sin resultados consistentes edison
cáceres seguidor de castillo no quiere
que abandone el poder
ni siquiera en la actual situación
económica que le ha hecho perder su
poder de compra lo anima a quitarle su
apoyo si se produjera una vacancia
presidencial que dios no quiera y el
pueblo no quiera
nosotros vamos a botar sangre lágrimas
sudor como siempre vamos a defender a
nuestro presidente
ulises rodríguez y sus amigos buscan
judicial izar sus reclamos salariales y
laborales la incertidumbre es la única
compañera mientras los peruanos esperan
que el país salga de la inestabilidad en
que está sumergido desde hace cuatro
años pedro castillo derrotó a sus
opositores y se libró de un proceso de
impeachment pero cometería un grave
error si es que no acciona cambios en su
gobierno y en los funcionarios que lo
rodean el mandatario tiene la
oportunidad de rectificar sus
desaciertos y tender puentes con el
congreso y con los grupos económicos
sólo así su administración conseguirá
gobernabilidad y llevará tranquilidad al
país también debe concentrarse en sacar
al perú del estancamiento económico y
social que atraviesa y que se ha
agudizado con la pandemia del cob y 19
que ha cobrado la vida a más de 200 mil
peruanos te noto más rápido las riendas
del país casi o corre el riesgo de que
el parlamento lo saque del poder como
ocurrió con el ex presidente de martín
vizcarra gracias por acompañarnos en
este programa fin de año desde lima perú
sigan disfrutando de la programación de
france 24 en español y hasta pronto